yes
happy a happy Wednesday
everyone
a they're basting me with
Applause so by now you've heard the
phrase trump derangement syndrome but
maybe it's time it graduated from
syndrome to disease because while A
syndrome refers to symptoms a disease
refers to an established condition and
Trump derangement is just that it's a
disease much like alcoholism where what
defines it is an incapability to process
booze and that delicious Maga Martini is
Trump no pill can stop it no therapy dog
or therapy llama can alleviate it those
who have it are already paranoid but
they're also loons with Annoying wives
who are most susceptible the most recent
victim Joe Scarboro who was left
emotionally Scarboro by the 2016
election Joe wasn't always like this he
used to look like a normal person but
now he has the same eyes as the kid
playing the banjo in
Deliverance it's amazing could be the
same person same age really and as
you'll see eventually your mental
functions totally deteriorate to a point
where even the view is over your head so
as a public service here's what a trump
aholic sounds like he's not a normal
candidate he is running to end American
democracies we know it he will imprison
he will execute whoever he's allowed to
imprison execute uh uh uh uh drive from
the country ju just look at his past
it's not really hard to read I just keep
wondering what she's thinking while he's
doing
that sorry beas we are looking at
Trump's past and it's pretty easy given
he's the most investigated transparent
political leader in history and I said
transparent not translucent like by and
see-through
skin and so far there's no imprisoning
executions no ending of democracy in
sight but it's clear how the ugliness of
addiction can sap your memory and
reasoning ability as you heard Joe
believes that if Trump becomes president
he's going to execute those who don't
agree with him but when Trump was
President he executed exactly no one
well except for solmani and that guy
didn't have to watch Morning Joe to wake
up to a
bomb
Joe also claims it's Trump's mission to
replace American democracy with a
dictatorship now as the Commander in
Chief Trump controlled all of America's
Armed Forces even the nukes yet hostile
Nations like Russia North Korea and
Canada are still
standing also actual dictators usually
die in office or are assassinated or
take a helicopter full of money to
Europe instead Trump gave up power to a
scile guy who sniffs little
girls and then Donald happily went back
to his golf game and now he just does
stand
up he's not into golden showers as they
say they call that he's not I don't like
that idea Adam Shifty shift with a neck
like a pencil he's got I said how does
he how does he hold up that fat ugly
face with a neck with a
neck pencil NE did anybody ever hear of
alons Capone he was so mean if you
looked at him in the wrong boy had blow
you away he was only indicted once I got
indicted four times in a matter of
seconds you know he sounds less like a
dictator and more like Don
Rickles but you see how bad it is you
hallucinate you start seeing all sorts
of stuff that just never occurred they
should change the name from Morning Joe
to morning
sickness uh what do you
say but sadly it's now running rampant
at
MSNBC a lot of people have tried to draw
similarities between musolini and Hitler
and the use of the terminology like
Vermin the difference though I think
makes Donald Trump even more dangerous
and that is he has no philosophy he
believes in all he wants is to look in
the mirror and see a guy who's President
all he cares about is selfish
self-promotion I'm beginning to think
there's something in the water over at
MSNBC besides
anti-depressants
they got Trump on the brain and almost
nothing else apparently including
history when you say Trump is worse than
Hitler what you're saying is what Hitler
did killing six million Jews among
others wasn't nearly as bad as Mean
Tweets and jokes about Rosie o
Donal no wonder you see young leftists
brandishing swastikas in protests
apparently Hitler is just some guy who
did stuff this is next level
anti-Semitism Claire meanwhile back on
Earth Norm Al Americans are concerned
with what we all know is common reality
here in the US 70% of Americans are
worried about the economy which they see
getting worse on crime according to a
recent gout poll 40% of Americans are
afraid to walk home alone at night
although some are used to the
loneliness yeah just leave it on them
over a third are afraid to drive in
areas of their communities these are not
hallus Nations these are the real
experiences of the American people so
it's no wonder Americans have bought
more guns than you'll see in judge
Janine's wreck room 52% of Voters say
they or someone in their household owns
a firearm just a decade ago 42% said
they owned a gun cat that's 10
points fear of crime is at its highest
point since
1993 why is that well it demonstrates
another reality the addicts can't see
that what they accuse Trump of is in
fact going on right now in the current
Administration like most addicts they
live in denial and will lie to your face
about what you and I can clearly see
with our own two eyes and in San
Francisco smell with both nostrils for
instance it wasn't dictator Trump who
weaponized the Department of Justice
with a conga line of special prosecutors
wasn't Trump who sicked the FBI on
parents wasn't Trump who raided an
innocent anti-abortion protesters home
with guns drawn wasn't Trump that
prosecuted Trump for having documents he
was allowed to have although that trial
would be hilarious wasn't Trump who used
doj to get Twitter and other social
media to do its bidding on covid it
wasn't Trump who set up a select
committee that buried important videos
to Fashion a pre-ordained verdict
regarding January
6 see what Morty Joe did is what shrinks
call projecting or as most of us call
it
thank
you and for those of you who are
non-binary bull
sheit that way they can't bleep it see
they can't bleep it if I say bull she
it yeah but to the Trump addicts on the
left little things like the well-being
of the American people don't register it
means about as much to them as personal
hygiene means to a somebody hold up in a
crack house according to the New York
Times the Democratic party that tried to
quit Donald Trump for three years has
fallen off the wagon now they're looking
to put Trump front center at every
opportunity of course they wouldn't do
that if they actually feared he'd
execute him or them but now they long
for the days when cable networks carry
Trump's rallies live and why well they
need something to deflect us from what
they've done to the country without
Trump around then all you got filling
the airwaves is
this
yeah is there any Wonder America's dams
have decided the best way to win next
year is to lean into their addiction to
All Things orange they know this country
is not going to vote for the guy in the
basement again hell he might not even
survive the stairs down to the
basement so they want their Obsession to
become your obsession forget the economy
forget crime forget nuclear war focus on
Trump which may not be a bad idea the
way the polls are looking hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else